Welcome and welcome to this video where
We will show you all the exciting new features
In Google Play Services 4.3.
If you are new to Google Play services
You've come to the right place because Google Play services
Amazing.
But if you are a software developer, this is great news for you
Because you will get the latest
The amazing things we create here at Google.
And will integrate them into your applications.
Let's take a look at the key features of this release.
First, we'll show you the new Address API interface,
Then we'll look at some of the great new features
For Google Play game services.
We'll also describe the Analytics and Google Tag interfaces
Manager API are two new additions to services
Google Play.
We will end this video with a view
New things in the Google Drive Android API.
Let us start.
Ladies and Gentlemen, Here's the new API interface.
Welcome to the Address API interface with warm applause.
Go back to work.
Okay Sir.
How many of you tried to buy something
Online through his smartphone
Then he reached the part where he must
Write the delivery address.
Oooff, an unpleasant experience.
Big fingers on small keys.
But no doubt, if you want to shipping to your current location
You can use the Location API
To fill in the title, this makes things easier for you.
But what if you are at work
You wanted to ship what you bought to your home?
Here exactly can interface
Address API that is blowing to help you.
With this interface, your app can provide a user interface
Displays all addresses recorded by the user.
The user can then select an address
Such as (John Smith) in the example shown in the picture,
And so on.
The address will be available for the great bike shop
To complete the purchase.
Time will no longer be wasted because of the large fingers and small keys.
Is not that great?
Shopping with your smartphone is like taking a walk
Thanks to Google Play services.
Now go to the Google Play Games services.
The number of mobile games is now greater than ever.
We continue to add new features to this interface.
Through this release, we launched Game Gifts
Which allows players to send virtual requests within the game
To anyone in Google+ circles or through the search function
About the player.
The player can now send Wish Request
To request a feature or element within the game of another player.
The other player can send Gift Request
To grant an item, feature, or something,
This is both players happy in the end.
This feature completes the multiplayer functionality
Which were issued earlier and will promote social participation
Among the players in your games.
One example of using gifts is to ask for more play times
From your friend in case your game times are over
in the game.
Be careful.
Use this short video for the LiquidFun Physics Engine.
I strongly invite you to see it.
There are great things that Google Play services offer,
Be sure to use them all in your games.
Now go to the Google Analytics and Google Tag interfaces
Manager API.
[Background music]
Ladies and gentlemen, this is true, these two fronts are new.
Welcome to Google Analytics and Google Tag
Manager API hot applause.
Go back to work.
Okay Sir.
These two fronts have in fact been presented as independent fronts
But now fully integrated into the API interface series
For Google Play services.
This is great because it limits the memory footprint
Of your application and these two interfaces can be used side-by-side
With all other interfaces making them ready
For use in creating this wonderful app.
Let's take a look at the contents of these two faces now.
We'll start with the Google Tag Manager interface
Which enables you to use tags in your application instead of embedded encoding values.
These tags replace the values
That you stored in Tag Manager at run time.
This can be used for example in background color management
Your application, game settings, and translation settings.
Because tag values ​​are stored in Tag Manager,
This excludes the need to transfer the entire application
From Google Play again;
You can easily change the tag value in Google Tag
Manager.
This takes us to the Google Analytics API.
If you have not used Google Analytics before,
I strongly urge you to try it.
The Google Analytics interface puts detailed statistics in your hands
About how your app is used by your users.
For example, the functionality of your application
The most frequently used or activity is paid
Users to switch from applying ads
To a paid application.
This knowledge can be very useful
In delighting your users
And get your next monthly paycheck as well.
So do not miss out on the Google Analytics API
Because it can provide a lot of valuable information
is yours.
This takes us to the Google Drive Android API.
As you know, Google Drive released the Android API
Officially in the latest version of Google Play services
This is often a good start
With group API interface enhancements.
The first of these improvements is the installation.
You can now install files that should be
Updated locally.
This ensures that the application can use these files
Even when the user is offline.
As well as this, our application folders allow for your application
Creates files that the user can no longer see.
Such as storing temporary files in a picture editor,
This function is similar to a data folder
App in the Google Drive API that was used for a short time.
In this release, we also have "Changes Notifications"
Which allows re-logging
And receive a notification when a file or folder is changed.
That means you no longer need
To query the drive continuously to verify that the data has changed,
All you need to do is place a change notice
Your API will connect to you when the change occurs.
We've also added a number of improvements
On metadata information,
Something you can not do.
In order to meet your potential need for metadata information,
You will be happy to know that we are
We've added a set of new fields in this version.
We've addressed everything in this version of Google Play services
But stay in touch because we'll be announcing more.
Now it's your turn.
Get started and create great apps
And do not forget to tell us everything about your experience.